in the meantime the copen 19 mitigation  and management task force is meeting  right now  that group addresses issues throughout  the pandemic that includes compliance  with state guidelines  education and health care now the nevada  hospital associate association  just addressed the group about 30  percent of hospital patients are  confirmed right now to have cobit 19  and one challenge is health care  staffing of course there was a shortage  of nurses before the pandemic  and nurses are now needed even more  we'll have much more on this meeting  coming up for you at four  five and six o'clock right here on  channel eight